you will not protect the animal from
an ounce oea family criticized the
The Brazilian situation is this way.
government has not done much for
indigenous peoples but can a
legitimately elected
so we are very worried about
This is because who article this picchu
it was the ruralista bench
gospel that are radically
social movements in that country
mainly the individuals movement
entrepreneurs nor the agribusiness dispute
the earth listens to the earth as a place of
production and the indigenous people
territories
now it will get worse
our errand today I already to require of
government and not
revocation of decrees and ordinances
declared published in government
dilma
it authorizes the project that
very much our lands the environment to
nature
We do not expect much from him.
to war we will go to war